[Music]
in our series the new normal we look at
how the pandemic is dramatically
changing our everyday lives the hard hit
restaurant industry expects to lose
about 240 billion dollars in sales this
year
thousands of restaurants have begun
outdoor dining to keep their doors
open but they face new challenges as the
weather turns colder
vlad duce looks at how some are getting
creative
to keep diners warm and safe vlad good
morning
good morning yes winter is coming and
restaurant owners are working hard
to make sure their outdoor dining areas
are still available when that cold
weather arrives
some of their ideas include using
propane fueled heaters or even
insulated domes to keep diners warm and
their food hot
it's getting a little nippy yup
it's going to continue to get nippy
as temperatures start to drop restaurant
owner and chef alex reich is now faced
with a new reality
when restaurants were able to reopen and
business started to come back
but then you realize it was going to get
cold what were you thinking you would do
i'm always thinking about the worst i
feel like that's kind of my job
unfortunately the worst may not be here
yet
but chef alex is preparing to bring the
heat at her brooklyn restaurant levara
are you worried at all that people might
not want to eat
out here when it's cold definitely
as the industry reckons with the new
normal restaurants
around the country are finding ways to
provide warmth
and comfort for diners while continuing
to serve their dishes hot
it's pretty uncertain as are all things
right now we're just trying to figure
out what we're gonna do
already ailing businesses are spending
thousands of dollars on
outdoor heaters complimentary blankets
for diners
it's gonna just keep getting colder and
colder and what are we gonna
do about it and outdoor greenhouses
the pandemic is forcing owners to think
outside the box
or in some cases outside the bubble i
can tell you that with everything going
on in this world
eating in the bubble is about one of the
best experiences you can have
in detroit the east eats restaurant is
taking that experience to a whole new
level
by installing about a dozen insulated
domes we actually completely
transform all of our domes into igloo
domes then you're in like a greenhouse
like covering so you can be in there in
the rain
you can be in there in the snow it is
absolutely necessary to protect
you protect other diners in chicago
mayor lori lightfoot asked the public to
submit ideas for a winter dining
challenge
among the winners these cozy cabins and
heated tables
we have four of these here in brooklyn
while indoor dining resumes at 25
capacity chef alex is going all in on
outdoors
right now the best prospects are outdoor
dining
it's where most people feel the most
comfortable and i think people are
willing to
bundle up and tough it out chef alex is
still waiting from the city for approval
to use those propane fueled heaters one
other important note is that while those
insulated domes we saw can protect
diners from the cold
they are not proven to protect you from
the coronavirus they do encourage
customers to socially distance from one
another
and it is important to still wear your
mask when you are not eating
well no that's what i want to know you
want to go to the restaurant you've been
there you guys have both been to dinner
i've been inside a restaurant and i've
and i've eaten outside as well
and frankly i've been nervous both both
ways yeah i mean
those domes are so elaborate
particularly the ones in chicago it
feels like you might as well be
inside that's that's my view i mean
because i look at them and i think part
of the reason i want to eat outside is
so that there's air circulation
i don't when i look at those i like how
do you get air circulation yeah i'll
take the fdr blanket and that's going to
be my but you've been to that restaurant
i have with a blanket all right we'll be
right back
was it good yeah it was terrific